where are africa's ancient treasures
stolen for the most part it's a
well-known fact that the benin bronzers
were looted by british soldiers more
than a century ago and sold to
collections around the world a few have
now been returned others may follow but
what about the mandu yenu throne from
cameroon well it's here in berlin king
and joya gifted the throne to the german
emperor wilhelm ii in 1908 but how
freely was it given away
then there are older examples of human
heritage from africa this is the kubway
skull found in 1921 in what is today
known as zambia it's more than a quarter
of a million years old despite the
requests from the zambian government for
its return it's still in london
and then there's this a single slender
bone currently in the museum in brussels
belgium the shango bone excavated in
1950 is believed to be the oldest ever
example of human mathematics or its
understanding of human mathematics some
in the democratic republic of congo
where it was found insist the former
colonial power belgium should give it
back
dw's jack parrock reports from the
belgian capital
stored in a protective safe at the
museum of natural sciences in brussels
the ishango bone
three columns of up to sixty notches on
the bone divided into groups are
believed to prove a mathematical
understanding in early humans of
twenty-five thousand years ago
we have
a group of notches three notches and
then six notches
after that we have four notch notches
and then eight notches
and and then ten and five so we have
maybe a knowledge of
a number and is double the 10 centimeter
fossilized bone was found with the
quartz stone used to make the notches an
extremely rare find it was discovered by
a belgian geologist in 1950 on the shore
of lake edward in virunga national park
and brought back to brussels at that
time the country was under a brutal
colonial rule responsible for the deaths
of up to 10 million congolese people
it was a statement made by the head of
the drc's conservation institute which
has shone the light on this specific
item the ashango bone the
symbolism of the the coming back of this
bond in this place is so important for
us it's uh it symbolizes all the the
mission that we have today
to conserve the biodiversity and to
conserve the
the
nature
for the the well-being of humanity so
as you can guess the importance of this
little bone of tense antivirus is
tremendous for us on display in the
brussels museum is a replica of the
shango bone
there's been no formal request by
authorities in the democratic republic
of congo for the ashango bone to be
returned there yet
but there could be one and it could be
one of thousands of artifacts in museums
like this one
that might end up being returned to
where they were found the belgian
government has launched a wide-ranging
consultation along with the government
in the drc to discuss the return of
thousands of items stolen during
colonial times
the exact number in the consultation is
unknown the state secretary here says
the process must be done correctly the
entire philosophy of our approach
is that we want we don't want to talk
about any specific object because we
want to put science at the core of the
decision is it legitimate to be in
belgium then we can keep it or is it
illegitimate because the circumstances
historical circumstances are not good it
has been stolen and in that case it
should be returned much like this 25
meter high statue of the ishango bone
outside the brussels museum
many in the congolese community in
belgium believe the country needs to
talk bigger and address financial
reparations for the atrocities committed
now belgium was one of many european
powers that stole africa's heritage
across the continent colonialists took
what they wanted with impunity often by
force over the centuries tw news
africa's tomi alodipo met with a kenyan
activist who wants to find her heritage
now my next guest has been finding out
what was stolen from her country kenya
let's welcome dr joaquin gumi to dw news
jackie it's good to have you on the
program now you're active in the nest
which is an artist collective and
the international inventories program
these are all working together with the
national museums of kenya can you tell
us about this project and what you found
out
um i think first of all to kind of riff
off what you said my my heart of course
is with the people of uh the people
whose objects were taken um and who have
to find out about them in these deeply
deeply distressing um horrifying stories
um with regard to our work with iip and
the international inventories project
it's been really exciting to be able to
work so closely um with the national
museum which can look from afar like a
very kind of imposing institution
and the museum in the course of our
working together has grown an interest
in
getting back
some specific objects especially objects
that have been deemed objects of
national importance and also kind of
wanting to have custodianship of a
database of objects that we have um
crowdsourced and a lot of museums in
germany and in other countries have
contributed to to say these are the
canyon objects that we have
in our archives
object ownership is something that's
very complex and layered beyond even all
of the old and very boring um and of
course untrue
claims that africans don't have capacity
to keep the objects objects that were
made here for use here which of course
we have capacity to do
and of course noting that many of these
objects are not even represented
properly um in the archives that they're
in um in some of these museums abroad
they're given different names they're
attributed to different ethnic groups
and they actually belong to um beyond of
course some of them having left in very
dubious and criminal circumstances so is
the aim actually to to return these
items particularly the ones from kenya
back home
so that's a really good question i think
um for the for for our partners the
national museums of kenya they have
interest in very very specific objects
some which have been called objects of
national importance um and a few of them
um have been identified in our in the uk
one of them whose whereabouts are
unknown as the human remains um and of
course referring to him as an object of
of course is is very is very problematic
because human remains are not objects in
that sense but the human remains of
quite all arab subway who was a
spiritual leader who was very very
important to one kenyan ethnic group um
the kaling people
another object of course is um then
gadget which is a drum of the pokomo
people which they used to communicate
with those who had gone before them and
to have kind of rituals and things
around with regard to some of the
objects um of course it's very important
to start building ethical relationships
around them and i think this is possible
a lot of very
progressive museums have begun doing
this it's like how can we um first of
all have the truth with regard to the
provenance of this object unknown so how
can people know this is exactly where um
some of these objects came from do these
objects have the right names have have
they been represented properly
are there ways in which um the ownership
of these objects can be more reflective
of where they came from is it possible
to see especially with objects that were
taken in gruesome circumstances and some
of these objects are known can those
objects return and the others can there
be kind of constructive and and and
helpful dialogue towards um building a
much more a much more equitable cultural
relationship around these objects
you talk about the the the circumstances
around these artifacts but there are
other
issues related you know uh intangible
heritage that has been lost as well um
are those lost forever
i think that's a really good question um
the the conversation around the objects
is just the beginning um it's not just
cultural objects that were taken and for
us um objects have been made a focal
point to distract from so much else one
thing um especially that africans would
like to get a hold of is the colonial
document archive um each and every
single um each and every single colonial
colonial entity um in africa was was
very intentional about documenting
everything they did everything that was
taken
people who were killed and all of that
and a large number of people were able
to destroy a number of these documents
of course because they knew they would
be incriminating if they were ever found
by the countries where they were where
these atrocities were committed but some
of these
some of these documents still exist um
and are there so getting a hold of some
of those things on top of and including
objects um i think would be the
beginning of a true of a true
possibility of something that's a little
bit more equitable that acknowledges um
how much damage the power dynamic has
done um that this favors and and this
disadvantages africa and kind of puts
the global north in a higher position um
it i think it i think it does behoove me
to say that um the iap project um has
been supported by um by by german
partners and and that germany in
particular have been very very
progressive even though of course a lot
more canon should be done but germany
have been very very progressive about
facing these very very difficult
questions
quite a lot of work uh to be done as as
you put to us uh dr joking gumi from the
nest collective in nairobi many thanks
for speaking to us
absolutely thank you for having me and
looking forward to continuing this
important important conversation
and this congolese activist decided to
take matters into his own hands by
storming museums in europe to steal some
of these items back take a look
manny would call this theft but this
activist says he's only getting back
what was taken away from his people
i came to reclaim goods that were stolen
from africa during colonialization
this video was live streamed on facebook
back in june um
and four other activists were trying to
steal a funerary post from cabrilli
museum in paris he failed but managed to
draw attention to a topic that has
recently triggered a heated debate
should african art looted during
colonialism be returned
and if so how and when
the congolese burn activist says action
is needed now
you never ask a thief for permission to
get back what he stole from you
that's what we did we have the right to
defend ourselves because we were robbed
the fact that our works are on display
here means the theft continues
also caused a stir when he tried to
steal a piece of art from a dutch museum
as well as in the french city of
marseille
some say these acts have to be
considered as performances not as theft
it's a different way of saying things
that have already been said in many
forms for a long time since african
countries gained independence on a
diplomatic level in a dialogue between
museums in international cooperation
for diabetes and his fellow activists
it's not only about bringing heritage
back home as he calls it he also wants
european societies to face the realities
of their colonial past
now a report by france found that up to
90 percent of african artworks are held
outside of the continent the man who is
trying to get them back you saw him in
that report is activist mazulu diabanza
our tommy aladupo asked him if he had
achieved what he wanted
we're not
yes our goal was to win over
international public opinion which we've
done
our second objective was to spark a
debate and the debate has been sparked
we've succeeded in putting the issue of
restitution back on the international
media and political agenda
i've just returned from kinshasa where
there was an international symposium of
scientists on this issue
many governments and many associations
are mobilized around
there have been some cases of
restitution uh where some of these
artworks are actually being moved back
uh are you hopeful that everything that
was stolen and placed on display in
europe will be returned
this is the core of our struggle all
that's been taken from us all that's
been looted and stolen
everything that's been the target of
illicit trade and trafficking must go
back to africa
these first restitutions are proof that
we've made progress since our action of
so-called active diplomacy on june 12
2020 at the kai branley museum
and then again in several other european
museums
we're convinced that our chosen method
the mechanisms that we're putting in
place and the road of return we're busy
building
that will result in the return of
everything
you've been prosecuted for your actions
did the european courts find you guilty
and if so what was your punishment
i was convicted in paris but in
marseille we were acquitted on the first
count
and in the netherlands convicted on the
second count
these are just persuasive measures
because all the judges unanimously
recognize the political character of
this act
obviously they also recognize the
absence of any characteristics of theft
that's to say any intention from us to
possess these objects ourselves
they understood of course that they
could not judge this act because then
they would also have to judge the crimes
committed against the african people
during the slave raids during slavery
during colonization during
neocolonialism
so a trial on this issue may be
untenable
the courts are just trying to prevent me
from doing what i'm doing
we're continuing our work despite these
convictions
which seem unjust
and we've appealed almost all of these
convictions
okay now you've said that the theft of
these artifacts
stole africa's spirit and identity so
what would their return
mean for the continent
it's the reconciliation first of all
with ourselves
the reconciliation with our past
and the reconciliation with our history
and with our ancestors
many people when they saw me do this
i take the example of my brothers who
are in suriname
they saw in this act the return of all
the deportees to our motherland africa
that's to say that the recovery of what
was stolen from us
and i continue to believe that the
restitution of this looted african
heritage
locked up in different museums will
allow africa to rebuild its cultural
edifice
the house of african culture that was
destroyed
and will allow us to repair the backbone
of our identity and our cultural roots
allowing us to stand upright once again
okay
dear banza many thanks for speaking to
us